how about a trivia question chris to
determine the first pick what do you got
uh sunday tom brady could be the second
quarterback to start a super bowl for
both an afc and an nfc team who was the
first to do so
craig morton yeah yeah
it took me
it took me a minute like when i first
saw the question i was like
wait who the who is this but once you
started cowboys and broncos cowboys and
broncos i don't know which cowboy super
bowl it was it was either five or six i
missed five five that horrible game
against all boxes right 16 jim o'brien
jim o'brien
kicker field goal losing mvp right only
time that's ever happened
from from my hometown chuck hallie right
for the warwick vikings wow
sorry chuck so you got to live near
mike floria at one point sorry
he didn't live near me i don't even know
him i just know he's from the same town
all right uh i get the first pick it's
goat versus goat are you kidding me tom
brady versus aaron rodgers it's a goat
race baby how can that not be the top
matchup even though they won't be on the
field at the same time unless something
really creative is done defensively by
one of the teams brady versus rogers we
thought we'd see it in the super bowl
this is the next best thing yeah well
yeah it is i you know
okay well yeah i mean i i don't like
that draft pick okay it's it is but i'm
not gonna let you take my homes and
allen then with the second pick all
right so i'm gonna take that
because i'm not and i'm gonna take the
guys that are in the prime the young
studs okay forget those old-timers those
gray-haired guys all right who would you
have taken if you had the first pick i
think
you were taking brady and roger no no i
really would have had to think about
this i'm actually more excited to watch
mahomes and allen
i think i under the the big picture of
nfl history and all that i guess is more
on the rogers tom brady thing right now
but i'm still i don't give a damn i'm
not going to let you take both
quarterback match up so i'm taking allen
and my homes yeah they're the two
most talented young quarterbacks we got
in the sport
they have played at a different level
this year you know and and really josh
allen this year mahomes for the last few
years you know we know rogers is right
there in that conversation too but just
as far as pure backyard playmaking
nobody's better than these two
quarterbacks and i do think there's
something personal here where both guy
wants to be the young stud who's the man
and they're gonna try to outdo each
other so even though i don't like to do
the quarterback quarterback thing i'm
gonna do it because i don't want you to
have another pair of them on your draft
board
pete is lobbying very aggressively in
the document that we share
maybe two we pick people who be on the
field at the same time so so pete let me
do what i can to make even more upset
andy reid versus sean mcdermott this is
shakespearean but no andy reid fired
sean mcdermott 10 years ago he fired him
the top headline at pft right now is
that andy reid says sean mcdermott
should be coach of the year okay it's
too late to try to fix it andy you fired
him 10 years ago you told him pack your
bleep and leave
that makes that match up that battle of
wits that handshake at midfield
everything it's he fired him it's
beautiful and and uh
yeah you know i don't i i don't know how
it plays out but one guy fired the other
great matchup in my mind yeah no no
doubt about that you're right and i
think this works i mean it's offensive
coach versus a defensive coach so
there's legitimacy there to this one i
don't think pete can complain too much
i i like that i do okay that's that's a
good one um all right i you know i think
in that game i'm gonna stay with that
game too with one that i just find
interesting
uh
chris jones versus the interior three of
the buffalo bills the buffalo bills are
a very good pass protecting football
team we know that chris jones as we've
said all year long other than aaron
donald is the best interior pass rusher
in football
for me kansas city is not going to be
able to go crazy blitz against josh
allen you know it's the first time
they're going to play a quarterback
that's a lot like the guy on their own
team where you just go wait we can't
blitz him
he can block it up he can make us miss
he can throw bombs off his back foot we
got to be careful so i think chris jones
is going to have to get pressure and
make plays if they want to win the game
to disrupt josh allen and all that that
to me will be a big factor that match up
right there
all right last one for me and this is
simple and if you've been watching the
show all week first of all thank you
second of all you shouldn't be surprised
by this devin white versus anyone who
happens to get in his way yeah because
that guy is a machine he's aggressive
not too aggressive he's feisty not too
feisty he's incredibly athletic he's
strong he will hit you he will pick you
off he will pick up a fumble
on the fly in a way that many defensive
players can't and he's the heart and
soul of that defense and if he's locked
in like he was in the second half of the
game on sunday i said it before if he
plays like that for the next eight
quarters buccaneers win the super bowl
you can't even run outside on the tampa
bay buccaneers i would tell the green
bay packers that this week go don't even
waste your time calling those plays no
chance he is going to run your butt down
before you get to the line of scrimmage
if you run outside and levante david
will do it on the other side so good
luck with that that's a good pick by you
all right then some of the receiver
corner match-ups in this weekend i'm
really interested in i think the one i'm
going to go with is jair alexander
versus mike evans
because i think green bay has to worry
about the bucks o line steamrolling them
a little bit to where it's going to be
some one-on-one situations and if the
green bay packers want to win jair
alexander is going to have to have some
success locking down evans one on one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports